Stephanie is with us in Georgia
hi Stephanie welcome to the Dave Ramsey
show hey how are you I am currently an
uber driver and I pull in approximately
I would say 30 to 50,000 a year
I have education my education goes up to
a masters and my student loans is
actually well my total loan is a hundred
one moment I'm sorry
I think it's like a hundred and fifteen
thousand and my credit cards I have
credit card that's as well it's not
listed on the Credit Karma what I'm
looking at because I think they're in
collections I mean they are in
collections that's probably why it's not
listed so I'm looking at probably like a
hundred and fifty thousand dollars in
debt I try looking for jobs I was going
on interviews but I have no luck I have
the education behind it I have
experience but I just have not been able
to land a decent job what's your
master's degree in it's a it's a
marketing you have an MBA with
specialization in marketing um yes so I
won't consider MBA because that's like
extra time in school it's more of a
master's always like does that make
sense like it just says Emma that's what
they told me they're like it's a message
okay you can get an MS without it being
an MBA but they're the same thing and
both are master's degrees master's in
business administration is an MBA
master's and marketing is what you have
that's fine okay right right which
really doesn't get you anything if you
don't know how to do marketing but um so
okay how old are you I am 27 okay
and you dramatically overpaid for this
degree then didn't you just education in
general it's more of a cultural thing
like my parents are very big no it's not
a cultural thing it's a math thing you
overpaid to get a master's degree in
marketing it's not a cultural decision
it's just you paid a hundred thousand
bucks to get some you should've paid
twenty thousand for
it's not I didn't just say that but it's
just my total education I know yeah you
know yeah you paid too much so I'm
thinking that this was the golden ticket
and this was Willy Wonka and it's not
okay so you're 27 you're driving uber
you got a big butt pile of debt and we
need to get you a marketing job where
you can make 50 doing that and drive
over on the side right and double your
income so we can plow through this real
quick so what I'm going to do is I'm
gonna hook you up with Ken Coleman stuff
Ken Coleman is one of our Ramsey
personalities is a best-selling book
called the proximity principle it's a
proven strategy to land you the job you
love and it'll help you on this process
you don't have a ton of experience in
marketing it's mathematically impossible
because you're 27 and you've gotten and
you've been in school long enough to get
a master's degree which means you might
have 12 months experience in marketing
maybe so you're not like super
experienced but you're a sharp young
lady you should be able to land
something hold on I'm gonna send you a
copy of the proximity principle book to
help you get your career on track that
will give you the mind clean up this
mess